Robin can you share with us one of your
toughest days here in LA maybe an
audition gone bad or whatever and then
how you turned it around oh yes I
remember this very very well I had
finished I had just come off of my first
television series it was the very first
television series ever on cable it was
called brothers it was on Showtime it
ran for five years
and I had come off of that show and now
I had one year so this day that you're
asking about occurred I had gone through
one calendar year of going of having
deals made for 12 new shows okay
so I went out on my auditions it was me
and a couple of other people you know
signed my contracts everything was ready
and I didn't get one of the shows not
one of them so this isn't auditions that
I didn't get these are deals that were
made for me that if I had walked out of
the room with the job I would have had
another television series and I went one
calendar year twelve of those events and
didn't get one it was down to me and two
other women and most discourage me one
of the episodes was down to one of the
pilots was down to me and nobody else
and I still didn't get it because the
producer writer decided that she wanted
to play the role now none of those shows
ever went on to become serious but that
didn't mitigate my feelings on this
particular day and I was crushed I mean
it it was the hardest I couldn't believe
that this is what had happened again in
this year and I literally went on my
face on the rug and I just wept and wept
and wept and I and then I said God you
know if this I just want peace I want to
be happy if you think that I'm supposed
to move to Kansas raised chickens that
have babies I'll do it I just want a
sign I have to know I have to know
something I can't take this any longer
this this amount of continual rejection
after getting so close to so many things
and I and I stopped crying because I
really liked the rug and I was getting
schmutz on it so I had to quit but so
after right after I said the thing I
need a sign I have to have something
that is unequivocal the phone rang it
was my agent I was had an audition for a
movie with the then very old and ailing
I believe Robert Mitchum but it was
still Robert Mitchum and it was an old
movie star and I'd watched him when I
was a little girl and and I was really
excited about the audition and and OH
and then I had been something about I
had this feeling I often will open a
book you know with a metaphysical or
spiritual or just and just see what I
see right and I opened up I think it was
the Bible and it was something about
returning home as echoed desert Zephyr
returning you home and I got this so I
need a sign the phone rings I have this
audition then I do the thing I get the
reading about the Zephyr that feeling to
go home I got this overwhelming desire
to return to Aspen Colorado which is
where my parents owned their own
legitimate theater when I was a child
and I so I said I'm gonna do it and I
made reservations and the name of the
plane the the train that went there was
the Zephyr and and I went on the
audition I didn't get it but I had my
sign interest you know it was if this is
all I said if this is just my vanity let
me know because I don't want to do this
any longer and if it's not if it's not I
felt like this is what I was supposed to
do all the signs when I came here I got
work right away I got my sag card right
away I got an agent right away and and
and then I didn't work for a while
you know and then I got jobs here and
got jobs there and and you know waited
Tate what did waited cocktails at the
improv and at the Comedy Store and all
that in between gigs and
and and so so I got in all these signs
so I really believed that this and I
grew up on stage and this is what I love
and so I thought well you know I've had
all these other signs that things are
right that's what I thought I was
supposed to be doing but you let me know
if I'm not and so when that call came I
felt well that is definitely a sign you
know so and then I think oh and then I
went away on the trip and I came back
home and on my deck outside my door was
a a script for Murder She Wrote
and an offer to come and do it no
audition Wow just on the basis of the
work of mine that they'd seen before
they offered me the job and I thought
well that's my debt that's my
exclamation point on the signed that I
asked for but that day Karen that day
and wrung me out and I think a lot of
people will have those on the rug
moments yep and and I think they think
that it's it's just them but I think
isn't that just a part of how that
location of being in a town where it's
so competitive right and you just have
to realize it will come and then you'll
get back up again right if you want to
but the other thing that is critically
important to take away from this is if
you get the feeling that this isn't for
you that you would rather have a more
stable sort of life there is no failure
in that the failure is not trying the
regret comes from not trying if you went
and believe me if you come to Hollywood
and you live here for a few years and
you get a few jobs here and there and
then you decide it's not what you want
to do you are still gonna have a lot
more interesting stories to tell around
the old water cooler at your job that
you let packard or wherever it is that
you you end up working because you had
an adventure out here in in you know
Hollyweird you know you've all the
characters and all the strange things
that happen to you in the experiences
and the celebrities that you either
brush shoulders with or actually broke
bread with or knew you know you'll
you'll have a great story in a great
chapter of your life
so the
that is you know going back to another
question you asked about what aspects of
the book of people responded to giving
having been given permission as it were
to change your mind is incredibly
empowering it's incredibly empowering
you didn't fail if you chose to go
because you didn't like how you felt
here you win
you came you tried you had some
experiences and you went and you said no
not for me I'd rather do this because
you have to make a lot of compromises in
this business there are a lot of family
events that you don't get to go to even
if you're it's your child you know if
you have been in the business a long
time and you you know you don't get to
go to all the little league games you
don't get to go to all the family
celebrations sometimes because a job
comes up my the women in my family who
are some pretty stupendous women many of
whom have passed away in the last five
or six years they used to go on a trip
every spring to Rome or to Greece or to
Paris or to somewhere and it was just
the ladies and and they were a great
bunch of broads and that was a wonderful
trip and I'd buy a ticket every time and
every time I would have a pilot that I
would had to go you know that they made
my contract for and that I was either
get or not get and I had to cancel my
trips my living my real life with my
family and I didn't get them I didn't
get those pilots but you know the hope
of that big fish you know going away in
the springtime was out especially at
that time you know like 10 15 years ago
the pilot season fishing season you
catch your big fish you might be able to
live for years on the new show that you
that you just booked but I had to cancel
two trips with some of the most
interesting wonderful people for the
possibility of getting a job neither of
which I landed you know so it you
sacrifice for this business you know and
so make sure that if you for the time
that you're sticking it out that you
don't sacrifice your daily life to you
know go to the beach
you know celebrate
you